the VW scirocco is a 2+2 coupe a based
on the gulf the first generation dates
back to nineteen seventy-four the second
generation ended production in 1992 and
2008 with a third generation volkswagen
breathe new life into its desert wind
this yokel car tester on tight Zimmerman
identifies the Scirocco as his very
favorite model among VW's current ranch
mainly because it departs from many of
the core values VW seemed to stand for
nowadays other EWS generally provide
lots of space inside but even after
you've squeezed into this one you may
still feel a bit cramped piston Bank
welcome but it's more subjective feeling
at least in front objectively anyone 1
meter 85 or under shouldn't have any
problems that's just over six feet tall
we tested the Scirocco our production
model with a 2-liter TDI engine under
the hood it puts out 135 kilowatts of
power consuming 4.7 litres of fuel per
hundred kilometers book this Android
points out that even if the Scirocco
seems like a tight fit one getting in
after a few meters you feel almost like
a part of the car man fruit is crazy VI
entire from guns the Scirocco slow
flying frame comes into its own in the
handling the low center of gravity
reduces pitch and roll and the lower
seats give the car a sporty or ride
yes Yoko laundry feels that the Scirocco
is brimming with character and emotion
that makes it more fun to drive a
highlight for him is the three extra
instruments atop the dash the boost
pressure gauge for example though he
sees it more as a gimmick that loses its
appeal after a few kilometers there's
also a gauge for oil temperature he says
VW can integrate these things in almost
any car but it's especially important in
the sports models where the driver needs
to know when the engines heating up and
when he or she can go for maximum
performance well I Singapore can
our test car included the optional
multifunction sports steering wheel the
sport package costs around 600 euros
extra
the diesel aundrea surprised how much
fun it is to drive the diesel in his
test car after 2100 revs it brings out
the steam hammer as he says but
typically for a diesel the last thousand
revs of 4000 or higher are more or less
hot air otherwise it packs a punch tamia
highest aloft a bar alastair for maxim
dominguez path
the sharaku's body design clearly
expresses more emotional than practical
considerations the windshield areas are
relatively small and the roofline slopes
down toward the rear
fuscia rocco's widely flared rear
fenders leave no doubt that this is a
sporty model and give a strong hint that
the cargo space behind the small hatch
and high rear lip is likely to be
minimal deshi aku Andre decides the
Scirocco is the Volkswagen for
individualists for people who value
design more than practicality even so
he's left with a bland taste in his
mouth and wondering the thief inherently
practical VW can ever be truly emotional